hace una década la nieve estaba por
todas partes aquí en el glaciar de
presena en los alpes italianos ahora
tres mil metros de altura el panorama es
inesperado miles de metros cuadrados de
lona cubren lo que queda para los
visitantes que descubren el lugar es una
sorpresa
hemos venido aquí para ver el glaciar y
dar un paseo pero de hecho está cubierto
esperemos que al menos sirva para
preservarlo
[Música]
realmente te hace reflexionar sobre el
cambio climático y su impacto en las
zonas de montaña
con consecuencias muy reales desde 1993
este glaciar ha perdido más de un tercio
de su volumen así que la empresa que
gestiona la pista de esquí decidió
intervenir se instalaron 120.000 metros
cuadrados de lonas estas telas
geotextiles reflejan la luz y protege en
el hielo alpino del calor del verano
mickelson o muerto útil y digamos estas
lonas son muy útiles gracias a ellos
conseguimos conservar nuestra pista de
esquí sin ella probablemente todo se
había derretido ya esto nos permitirá
reabrir la pista en noviembre cuando
comience la temporada de invierno
mientras las estaciones invernales
cristian caserotto es glaciólogo para el
cubrir los glaciales no es una cura
milagrosa para preservar todos estos
ecosistemas
y tienen un pozo no estaré las flores
descubiertas no pueden considerarse
soluciones para el cambio climático sólo
pueden instalarse en glaciares pequeños
y ya chase solo de pico la dimensión lo
que realmente podemos hacer para
contrarrestar el deshielo es reducir las
emisiones de gas de efecto invernadero
responsables del aumento de la
temperatura efecto ser responsable del
lanzamiento de la temperatura si no se
hace nada se estima que los glaciares
alpinos por debajo de los 3.000 metros
de altitud desaparezcan a finales de
siglo